you step up here well I'm great I'm
about to give you some champagne so this
is gonna get even better let's fly in
the moet Bank alright so we are doing a
toast for a cause moet is gonna donate
$1,000 to the charity of your choice
what is your charity and why is it so
important to you it's called tenda i'm
patron of it so charity in the UK that
teaches children and young people and
young adults how to have healthy and
happy relationships and have therefore
happier lives absolutely yes I mean
that's the way to start off the globe's
Olivia let me take that for you
oh you'll keep keep keep it now let me
ask you I have to tell you I could just
listen to you say pretty much anything
you are the epitome of royalty you're on
a show about royalty you're nominated
here tonight how do you feel about your
chances going in oh I genuinely think
tonight might get a latte it's always an
honor to be nominated but I'm quite
quite excited about not making a speech
but you've won every time you've been
nominated I think you've got a good
track right there but it has to stop
some point and I think the category is
very strong and I and I think I think
I've had a bit of very lucky air and
it's someone else's turn
all right well we adore you we love the
show by the way is it true I heard that
your husband snaked some toilet paper
from Buckingham Palace got out of hand I
had a cold and so I said grab some bits
a new roll from the loo and now it's
become he stole a little Ralph but it
was a couple of bits of liberal the
toilet paper at Buckingham Palace even
better than regular I was hoping it
would have BP on it but it's it doesn't
it's very normal
thank you keep it keep it of course
[Music]